[Musik]
ja seit gestern ist es traurige traurige
Gewissheit Putin hat eines seiner ersten
Kriegsziele erreicht im Osten des Landes
hat er die Region luhansk wir haben es
gehört komplett unter Kontrolle gebracht
du Hans eine Region die bereits seit
2014 zu Hälfte wir sind das hier unten
das dunkle markierte von sogenannten pro
russischen Separatisten also nichts
anderes als Creme Marionetten und
russischen Geheimdienst dann gehalten
wurde und wo jetzt seit Februar die
Offensive im Norden tobte ja eine Region
gesehen ist die komplett von Russland
auch umzingelt ist wenn man so möchte
und insofern war es für die russischen
Invasoren hier natürlich besonders
einfach auch vor zu rücken Lissy Chance
wir haben es gehört wurde gestern
bestätigt von der ukrainischen Seite
auch zwei Tage nach der russischen Seite
dass sie verloren gegangen ist eine
Stadt mit jemals 100.000 Einwohnern und
gleich daneben ist sibirodonesk auch
eine große Stadt in der Region und wir
sehen uns mal Aufnahmen an die jetzt
nach der in Anführungsstrichen Befreiung
durch die russischen Armee entstanden
ist wir sehen also eine Stadt liegt
immer an eine Geisterstadt es gibt fast
keine Einwohner mehr man glaubt dass
etwa fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung also
etwa 5000 Menschen dort geblieben sind
die im pro russisch sind die anderen 95
Prozent sind geflüchtet aus der Stadt
und wir sehen wirklich die pure
Zerstörung also es gibt einfach nichts
mehr in der Stadt wo man irgendwie leben
könnte wovon man leben könnte oder was
noch auf wo noch einstellen auf dem
anderen steht insofern das hier einer
der Hauptstraße
wie wir gesagt haben seit etwa einer
Woche befreit wenn man so möchte oder
wie es ja kremme behauptet im
Wirklichkeit eben zerstört und zu
Geisterstadt gemacht und wir sehen uns
noch mal die Lage an denn jetzt ist
wieder du Netz die Region donezki die
wir unten sehen gefährdet du netstier
eine große Region wo wir die Schlacht
und mariopol gesehen hatten die Russland
gewonnen hat wo wir auch 2014 die
Schlacht um du Netz gesehen hat die
Russland gewonnen hat und jetzt sehen
wir hier Krammer Thorsten und slobiansk
die letzten beiden Ukrainisch gehaltenen
Großstädte und dort
schlägt jetzt der Terror Russlands zu
wir sehen ja Aufnahmen von gestern von
völlig zerstörten Straßen von mehrfach
Raketenwerfern ein bisschen russischer
Armee die hier auf Zivilisten geschossen
haben es gab sechs tote Zivilisten
allein bei diesem Angriff ukrainische
Feuer bedeutet die hier versuchen das
Schlimmste noch ja zu retten und die
Menschen natürlich zu retten und die
Menschen die einfach hier immer noch
leben auf dieser Seite der Front und
eben die die nicht evakuiert werden
wollten und ja sozusagen leiden unter
den russischen Angriffen das ist also
das was ihnen droht auch hier will der
kremme mit mit absoluten Terror mit
Zerstörungskraft eben die Menschen dazu
bringen sie zu vertreiben und danach
diese Städte wie sie wäre dann jetzt wie
jedes die Chance und viele andere Städte
eben erobern ohne ein einzigen Menschen
da drin was macht die Ukraine die
Ukraine setzt weiterhin auf westliche
Waffen und wir haben hier neue Aufnahmen
von der Heimat von einem mehrfach
raketenwerfersystem aus den USA das von
einigen vor einigen Wochen geliefert
wurde und damit versucht die Ukraine
jetzt immer mehr auch tief im
gegnerischen Gebiet also tief in den
Regionen die von Russland gehalten wird
zuzuschlagen und wir haben wir sehen uns
mal zwei
Erfolge an davon einmal letzte Nacht ins
Knie schnell etwa 70 Kilometer von der
Front entfernt sehen wir ja ein
russisches
Waffenlager was hier gleich explodieren
wird wir sehen also da gab es Einschläge
ukrainische Raketen oder eben
wahrscheinlich dieser Heimat weil es
eben sehr sehr weit von der Front
entfernt sind und wir sehen hier massive
Explosionen von waffenlagern dort ins
knieschnee in indonetzk kann das auch
noch mal kurz hier zeigen Snee schnell
liegt ungefähr
hier liegt es nie Schnee aber auch aus
Melitopol wir sehen das hier im Süden
militopol was auch schon sehr lange von
den russischen Invasoren gehalten wird
weil man dort von der Krim damals
vorgestoßen ist und das relativ rasch
erobert hat aus elitepol haben wir neue
Aufnahmen die zeigen das auch hier 70
Kilometer von der Front entfernt 70
Kilometer von der Front entfernt
ukrainische Angriffe Vorgehen wir können
das mal markieren das ist eine
Überwachungskamera die sowohl hier auf
der linken Seite als auch hier auf der
rechten Seite gucken uns das mal an
immer neue Explosionen zeigt immer neue
Feuer zeigt das ist ein russisches
Waffenlager oder die Ukrainer sagen ein
Hauptquartier der russischen Armee was
dort auf beiden Seiten brennt wir wissen
dass der unter anderem der Flughafen
aber auch ehemalige ukrainische Militär
Kasern hier von den Russen gehalten
werden das also die Hoffnung der
Ukrainer dass man hier indem man weit
hinter der Front zuschlägt den
russischen Nachschub doch noch ja so
sehr zum Erliegen bringen kann dass man
eben auch irgendwann wieder direkt an
der Front vorstoßen kann und das
eroberte Gebiet dann tatsächlich
befreien kann
[Musik]